of course the taking of reb and
mexican society in its armed forces
seven cannons in each
at 22 also military is
intimately related to the route
that made the facts of feelings
and serving support
expressions on the face because
the main component is the projection
of the  naval power but that also has
an important component to support
the population, especially in those
areas where access is difficult
important that Admiral
Vidal Francisco Soberón Sanz mentions on
a recurring basis but very very well it
also allows them to work in
coordination
is the  assembled group pp integrated
because in this case we see that the
military hatchery of santa gertrudis from
mexico has appeared to our Mexican sailors
because we thank them very much